bonjour fabrice epelboin merci de
répondre à nos questions dans quelle
mesure on a des informations sur les
réseaux sociaux est-elle amplifiée par
la crise du coc vide allez énormément
amplifiée par la crise de kobe tu parce
que la crise du coc vite se gère avec
essentiellement le fait de faire peur
pour inciter les gens à se vacciner
c'est à ce stade la seule véritable
stratégie qui a été mise en oeuvre et
qui marche il faut le reconnaître mais
elle a d'énormes effets secondaires et
parmi ces d'effets secondaires une la
perte de rationalité de tout un chacun
face à ce déluge d'informations et
énormément de gens se perdent dans cette
information d'autant plus que
l'information officielle
on l'a vu à travers cette introduction
de vous des doutes assez et c'est
souvent plus de temps et souvent elle
même chargée de fait news allez les
réseaux sociaux a dépassé donc pointé du
doigt pour cent sur intempestives oil
inverse pour manque de contrôle pourquoi
est ce que c'est si compliqué pour les
gens du numérique d'imposer des
barrières des garde-fous parce qu'il
faut le faire avec des algorithmes s'il
s'agissait d'être humains qui
regardaient chacun de ces messages et
qui prenait des décisions rationnelles
ça pourrait être faisable relativement
efficacement mais vu la quantité
faramineuse de messages on ne peut que
délégué ça à des algorithmes qu'ils font
énormément d'erreurs
et puis on ne peut également que
s'adapter à la vérité du moment
or on l'a vu avec cette fameuse affaire
du pangolin la vérité du moment et
fluctuant et le fait de stigmatiser une
information comme fait news pour
quelques mois plus tard revenir dessus
en disant que peut-être finalement la
vérité d'ailleurs contribuer à cette
confusion généralisée à cette
stigmatisation d'un côté des méchants
qui propagent défectueuse et des gentils
qui finalement s'avère propager eux
aussi énormément de fair use donc
nécessairement il ya une quantité
croissante de la population qui est
complètement dépassé par ces événements
qui essaye de trouver une vérité face à
un problématique est extrêmement aux
attentes et qu'ils n'y arrivent pas plus
que les autres mais qui se perdent dans
d'autres directions que la direction
officielle
on vient de le voir dans l'édito de
notre correspondante à moscou vera
goffman le fondateur
télégramme estime que la censure sur les
réseaux sociaux donnent crédit aux
thèses complotistes votre analyse il a
parfaitement raison ça s'est vérifié à
de multiples reprises le fondateur de
diagrammes opère des plateformes depuis
maintenant deux décennies il a cette
expérience de la lutte contre la
désinformation de la façon d'appréhender
des fausses informations à la façon
d'appréhender les théories du complot de
plus ou moins loufoques et effectivement
la censure crédibilise une information
particulièrement dans des pays comme la
france ou la russie dans lequel les
autorités politiques ont de moins en
moins crédibilité en france typiquement
on a moins d'un quart de la population
qui fait confiance au personnel
politique donc nécessairement six
semaines personnel politique censure ou
fait censurer et ben ils attirent
l'intérêt l'intérêt de la population sur
les informations censurées on les
crédibilise d'autant plus aux yeux d'un
nombre croissant de la population
la loi a bien contrôlé contenu haineux
sur internet a été rejeté en bloc par le
conseil constitutionnel en 2020 fin
juillet le canada a promis de forcer les
réseaux sociaux à agir quelle solution
législative selon vous ce sont les 16e
et très compliqué parce que là encore
elle repose sur la crédibilité d'un
personnel politique qui est totalement
décrédibilisé en particulier depuis la
création le début de cette pandémie donc
fondamentalement la seule chose que ça à
faire c'est faire changer les usages et
c'est systématiquement comme ça si on se
reporte sur d'autres problématiques qui
ont donné lieu à une forme de censure
comme par exemple la lutte pour le le
copyright on a fait changer les usages
du peer-to-peer vers le streaming et on
n'a absolument pas résolu le problème
qu'est la rémunération des auteurs
ce genre de stratégie peut avoir des
petits effets à très court terme mais à
moyen et long terme les effets sont
dévastateurs
merci fabrice un peu loin d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes enseignant à sciences po et
spécialiste des réseaux sociaux